how did the qc thing happen
uh
going to new york uh messing with my
manager and [ __ ] out there he ended up
taking me to his cousin ain't noodles
noodles new wine up
that why not hear my [ __ ] right now let
pete here
they flew me out there shout out to
wayne oh can you get closer
yeah a little closer to the mic please
is that better
just turn this mic up too yeah all right
cool
um so shout out to wayno uh so wayno
it was the one who kind of put you on to
to qc's radar for sure see that's the a
r thing over there
and they're super tapped in with detroit
now that they signed i swear vezo yeah
yeah that's my guy that's a great guy
man like uh
what do you think it is about detroit
right now that's kind of got music
because i feel like between detroit and
memphis y'all really kind of running rap
[ __ ] yeah they finally got a chance to
just like actually hear us
sometimes like back in the day i think
they were scared like we're going to get
some money and just do all violence with
the money you feel what i'm saying so i
feel like not at hearing this and seeing
like people really know how to rap win
just
yeah everybody like style actually come
from our city yeah i was gonna say
detroit's so influential
i feel like detroit and the bay area and
cali are so influential to the rest of
yeah yeah the trey and the bear are
definitely cousins
y'all rap on the same tempo of beets
you know what i mean like
same flavor some player [ __ ] going on
out in detroit we on the same time same
time you know
packs might get mailed
a lot of the plugs you know i mean might
be in the bay uh